Picture New York City and you’re probably
thinking about Midtown
Time Square, the Empire State Building, Grand
Central….
This is Midtown Manhattan
Tourist flock to it, while locals often try
- and fail - to avoid it
But there is more to this part of town than
tourist traps and traffic congestion
Midtown has been electrified by a bolt of
Brooklyn Hip and Wall Street money.
Maybe it's time you took a second look
Midtown is everything between 14th street
and Central Park South
It is the world’s largest central business
district
It also has some of the most expensive real
estate
And it doesn’t get any ritzier than Fifth
Avenue which commands the world's highest
retail rents
But if there is one building more responsible
than any other for midtown’s success
it's this one
Built in 1913, Grand Central Terminal helped
sparked a boom in construction that made Midtown
the center of American capitalism
This audacious building is used by more than
one million people a week.
A century after it was built it has only now reached capacity. That’s future proofing
New York embraces eating out. There are over
45 thousand restaurants in the city
It would take 125 years to eat in every one
- not saying your should
Here in Midtown - the restaurant scene is
embracing change
A number of Brooklyn institutions have jumped
the river
Roberta’s pizza started on the other side
of the East River in 2008 but their second
outpost is based in Urbanspace food hall - smack
dab in Midtown
You could be fooled into thinking this is
Williamsburg not Park Avenue
Another Brooklyn import is Ichiran, the Japanese
ramen chain whose first US restaurant opened
in Bushwick in 2016
.
Here you can sit with a group or…. in splendid
isolation in one of the so called ‘flavour
concentration booths’. Very serious
But if you want to swap Brooklyn cool for
something a bit more luxury
we've got the spot
The Office is an intimate speakeasy offering
pre-Prohibition style cocktails and a food
menu to match
You’ll find it hidden away on the 35th floor
of the super swanky Mandarin Oriental
This is one of the most expensive hotels in
New York, rooms start at $1000 a night
But there are 113 other hotels in Midtown
offering plenty of choices
So forget the old wisdom that the excitement
is basically, anywhere but Midtown
.
This part of Manhattan has something new and
exciting to offer, whether it’s high end
or rough-and-ready.